In this section for your stations,
we're going to demo the LED panel replacement
that you're going to be doing on your stage location.
At the Lantai stage, we're using the LED panel hardware
for the ROH Black Pearl II panels,
and things that you should note
is that there should be a backup panel
available for replacement modules.
Now each panel has four labeled modules,
and we're gonna show those in just a moment,
but they have a left top, left bottom,
right top, and right bottom,
and you'll only need to replace the module
with the same module location.
For example, left top to left top,
which is what we're going to be doing today.
Now as I walk through these steps,
you are going to be the one that does this
if you don't have a larger technician
that is actually onsite to manage your stage
and your LED panels.
For smaller steps, you may run into this.
Now it is recommended that when you do this,
you do have a second person,
and Sean Spitzer is going to join me while we do this,
and that will help ensure that you don't
accidentally drop or damage the panel during removal.
Now, as I showed you the other steps,
you can go back and view that to pause,
and then you wanna finish this
with these final steps to actually replace this.
Now we'll walk through these,
and occasionally I do wanna note,
and I will mention this again,
that the data cable will be disconnected
if it doesn't automatically re-sync.
Now let's switch over and take a look
at the hardware we're going to be working with today.
Now you'll see before me is a Black Pearl II from Rho,
and inside the panel I've already removed
the panel that we're going to be working with today.
So if I look at this panel,
you'll see that there are four quadrants,
and I've actually removed the left top quadrant
in preparation for the panel
that we're actually going to replace.
The back of this panel has several sections
that are in here,
and you can see the brain for the processor
and each of the individual panel units
that do connect in here.
Now additionally, I do recommend that you wanna make sure
that you have on hand a Phillips head screwdriver
or whichever one that is actually going to fit
within the screws that are inside your panel.
Now, as I said before,
we have already set aside this panel
in order to be worked with,
and this individual panel right here
is one of the four sections.
One of the things I wanna note here
is that inside each panel,
you'll see that there is a notation
for which panel it is actually located,
and the actual connector bracket right here.
We'll see those again up close
as we do the actual switch.
Okay, so now let's take a look at the panel
that we are ready here to replace.
Now you'll note I've already marked this panel
with some tape in order to note
that the panel itself is bad.
Now what constitutes a bad panel here
because it actually looks like it's going okay?
If you wanna take a closer look here,
this panel actually has some broken and dead pixels
right along this edge.
So you can see that there's some damaged pixels here
and here.
Now, if we move back behind this panel,
this is where we begin our replacement,
and you'll note here the corresponding number
and location information.
This tells me which panel is here
and the location, the left top located right there.
Now, as I wanna get ready and get started,
you'll note that I've got a blue light here
showing on my panel,
and all my panels are connected top to bottom.
Now to begin our panel replacement,
the first thing I wanna do is click right here,
move this out, and get that out of the way
so that this locking mechanism is out of the way.
Next, I'm gonna grab this silver connector,
push that up, and twist to remove this.
And I'm just gonna hide this right here
so it's out of the way while I work.
Now you'll notice these panels are now off,
and every panel below in the chain is off.
But above this chain right here is still active.
And that's because it feeds from top to bottom,
and each of these 10 panels, left to right,
are connected in a single chain.
Now, to unscrew them,
I just go ahead and unscrew,
and most of these are kept pretty finger loose
so that I can actually get to them pretty easily.
But if you need to make these adjustments here,
you may need a screwdriver, as I mentioned before.
Now, you'll also need to reach in
and get these loose as well.
But if you have an issue like me,
you'll wanna use the screwdriver.
Now, I know that this is actually interconnected
because if I push on this,
you can see that this screw is bouncing.
And that's because there's a magnet in here.
So if I press here, you can see that it moves a little bit.
Now, I'm ready to remove this.
I just pull this forward
so this handle is lined up straight,
and I put two fingers in between this handle.
And now, with ready and even pressure,
I just push straight ahead.
Now, since my hand has gone through this,
I hand this to Sean, who then takes over.
Now, as I mentioned before,
I wanna make sure that these brackets are here,
and you can see on this panel
while I grab the other one,
and Sean will show you on the actual brain
where that connector's located.
Now, you can see the pin here.
You have to be very careful you get these in the right spot
but it's pretty intuitive and easy to do
so you don't have to hammer it in.
So be very careful with that.
But they do have magnets which help us
with our location and putting things in place,
which is fantastic for the process.
So I'm ready again to replace my panel.
Now, my panel right now is upside down.
So I'm gonna turn this.
And the reason I know it's upside down
is because as Sean mentioned,
this connector here lines up with this connector here.
Now, to get these lined up,
I can go ahead and feed this to the bottom
so that this is here.
And there's little magnets here.
You'll notice there are four magnets.
This helps keep this in place.
So I'm gonna just line this up,
pop that in place, and it just fits nicely.
Now, I'm gonna move back
to the other side of the panel again.
And now I just need to return my screws.
So, starting with the bottom,
just line that up and screw that in.
And again, I wanna keep it pretty loose
just in case I need to replace it again.
Same with the top.
Get that in and screw that in
so it's just tight enough to keep it in place.
Now, I wanna replace this cable
and I go ahead and feed this back in and twist.
As that happens, light comes back on and it's red.
The indicators below are also red.
And in about 30 seconds,
this will turn blue and the front will turn on.
Slide that back in place
and now let's watch as these turn back on.
There will be times when you are putting
your LED volume panels back in.
They may need a little push or a little whack,
but again, take that with a grain of salt.
Every time is gonna be a little bit different,
but just be careful when you do it
and it should pop in just nicely.
There we go.
All set in place and back to normal.
Okay, so if your panels don't actually connect
and you don't see them all refreshing in the signal
after you connect here,
one of the things you might need to do
is remove this network cable
and reseed the network cable.
Once that happens, they should pop back on again
in 30 seconds.